cet immeuble vient d'être frappé l'un
des bases appartement est totalement
détruit par les flammes
les habitants effrayés tentent
d'identifier des survivants
les avions survolent toujours le
quartier
c'est un avion il faut à nouveau se
réfugier quelque part pas d'abri
souterrain à proximité juste ce hall
d'immeuble pour tenter d'échapper aux
bombardements
[Musique]
dans la cage d'escalier au milieu
d'autres résidents cette femme est
submergé par l'effroi
je n'en peux plus on n'a aucune
information n'est au courant des c'est
comme si on vivait en pleine forêt
les habitants de marioupol essaye de
survivre au coeur de cette ville
pilonnée sans relâche à chaque accalmie
ils sortent dans le froid pour chercher
de quoi manger de quoi boire au milieu
des ruines ce qui peut être brûlé sert à
se réchauffer plus d'eau courante plus
d'électricité et bientôt plus de vivre
le supermarché a été bombardé
on a perdu toutes nos réserves de
nourriture la situation est terrible
chacun essaie de s'entraider
et de rester en vie
les zones touchées par les bombardements
des quartiers résidentiels des commerces
et même des écoles
c'était une école élémentaire il n'y
avait pas de militaires ici on ne sait
pas pourquoi elle a été visée
sur ces images de drones diffusées par
les combattants ukrainien ces quartiers
périphériques de la ville sont en
flammes c'est là que les combats sont
les plus intenses une ligne de front
corps est franchie 160 voitures de
civils pour fear marioupol le ministère
de la défense russe affirme de son côté
avoir affrété des bus pour évacuer la
ville